c'est parce que la fille était jolie
sourd à sa chanson
[Rires]
Serge vous êtes né un deux avril je ne
dirais pas quelle année bélier donc
alors on va parler un petit peu du
bélier donc vous savez je crois que ce
signe porte à suivre ces impulsions sans
trop se soucier finalement des dégâts
que ça risque de provoquer c'est un
signe qui
c'est un signe qui porte également à
manquer de frein à manquer de retenue et
je voulais savoir s'ils étaient arrivés
bien que le bélier prédispose également
à ne pas trop revenir en arrière à
regretter certaines y retenus que vous
avez pu avoir
ce sont des flashbacks
comme ça je parle d'attitude comme ça
que vous avez pu avoir par exemple une
attitude je ne sais pas quand vous
insultez certaines personnes sur des
plateaux de télévision enfin en direct
on vous sabotez l'émission d'Eddy
Mitchell par exemple est-ce que ensuite
de ça vous vous mordez les doigts
d'avoir été aussi retenu aussi
[Rires]
je ne regrette rien quand je balance je
balance selon mes humeurs et comment
finalement parce que il faut dire quand
même que vous êtes Bélier à son poisson
son deux signes qui qui vont dans de
direction tout à fait différente et
comment
l'homme pudique que vous dites être et
que vous êtes que vous êtes comment
s'accomotive de l'exhibitionniste que
vous êtes également terrible
j'assume parce que je l'ai voulu ainsi
je l'ai voulu ainsi c'est
de prendre ma volonté
parlons un petit peu de du fait que le
bélier n'aime pas beaucoup les
contraintes les disciplines et plutôt la
personne attention du premier jet et je
vais vous demander si si on pouvait
imputer à cela le fait que vous vous y
prenez toujours au dernier moment pour
écrire
je stresse
je sais pas si
moi je pense que c'est un site bénéfique
bélier
le fait de revenir beaucoup sur les
choses c'est quelque chose qui est
difficile
quand vous avez oui non mais je veux
dire bon pour le travail d'écriture
quand vous avez travaillé par exemple
pour Vanessa Paradis je vous ai entendu
vous plaindre beaucoup du fait que quand
vous renvoyez vos textes à la figure
sous prétexte que c'était pas assez bien
donc on vous a obligé à revenir à
améliorer vos premiers gestes
un paradis ça en fait
quand je vous ai écrit comment te dire
adieu
mais est-ce que vous rendez compte que
par moment vous êtes beaucoup moins
lucide que vous ne prétendez l'être
vous en rendez compte bon c'est un bon
choix
c'est ainsi que j'ai fait mes
plus bouddhistes
ou des moments de tennis
mais c'est ainsi
vous êtes vous êtes né à une forte de
Vénus ça veut dire que vous êtes entre
autres Venezia moi je vous l'annonce
vous êtes en train de Vénusiens et quand
on est très marqué par cette planète
quand on est très marqué par cette
planète on s'ennuie quand on n'est pas
amoureux et je voulais vous demander si
vous ennuyez en ce moment
non je suis devenu
très lucide et ça sonne pas
si vous répondez à ma question
j'ai assumé mon destin
aussi aussi
cruel soit
je ne savais pertinemment qu'il serait
crevé
qui serait très dur
j'assume
et des coups de travail
moi je vous crois pas que vous dites ça
je crois pas que vous avez raison
qu'est-ce qui vous fait encore vraiment
plaisir là par exemple à projeter est-ce
qu'il y a des choses qui vraiment vous
réussissent à vous exciter suffisamment
encore maintenant
les miens
ah oui ça fait 400 000
blaireaux
les petits gars des petites cuisses
de platine c'est peu c'est dans
l'instant présent
oui parce que j'ai mon métier et puis
j'ai pas fini et je craquerai avec ça
j'adore j'adore la musique j'adore la
procéder j'adore la langue française
mais qu'est-ce qui fait que vous vous
commettez plus ou moins on comprend
mettez plus ou moins avec des avec des
artistes comme Joël Ursule par exemple
au stade où vous en êtes au stade vous
en êtes pourquoi pourquoi vous quelque
part vous rabaissez à faire des choses
comme ça qui sont quand même uniquement
commercial et très peu artistique de se
dire pas du tout
stade vous n'avez plus besoin de blé
c'est quand même c'est quand même
extraordinaire d'entendre ça dans votre
bouche vous n'avez plus besoin
en fait qu'est-ce qui vous a décidé dans
une chose c'est pas seulement le blé ça
doit pas être seulement le blé
c'est
pas vrai c'est parce que la fille était
jolie
sourd à sa chanson
[Rires]
bélier d'accord tous vos problèmes ne
sont pas résolus en ce moment pour vous
c'est pas le TGV alors parlez-en à vos
amis tout ira plus vite tAUREAU Vous
vous durcissez genre
carapace 100% béton tant pis pour ceux
qui vous prenaient pour un punching ball
il y aura du choco
autours
délaissé ça suffit sortez de vos gonds
papillonner zébulonnés fornicoter soyez
superficiel c'est bon aussi de temps en
temps Lyon Jupiter dans votre signe
bravo c'est très bien mais vous n'y êtes
pour rien alors levez le pied sur
l'autosatisfaction et soyez objectif la
grosse tête est limitée à 60
vierge sortait des prises de tête où il
n'y a rien à gagner qu'un peu d'amour
propre et des chevilles un peu plus
épaisses profiterez du 25
votre narcissisme ça éloignera les
critiques je m'aime je m'aime ça veut
dire quoi scorpion ouvrez-vous à l'est
au nord aussi prenez de nouveau contact
jouer les gorbits les Machiavel
simplement pour le plaisir de vous
compromettre
Sagittaire si vous aimez les
compétitions à couteau tirées vous
n'aurez pas à vous plaindre l'efficacité
de la batte de baseball de vos
adversaires côté sentimental ça sent
aussi l'arme blanche
Capricorne une bonne semaine pour jouer
les amnésiques côté problème du 24 au 26
question petit divan psychanalyse perso
vous risquez d'accoucher d'une surprise
Verseau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Verseau une situation à trancher le
style Rambo peut vous donner l'avantage
mais autour de 20 attention un chaos et
il y aurait de l'urgos sur votre orgueil
bobo poisson vous faites des bulles en
eau profondes loin des agitations
stériles vous méditez sur le sens de la
vie êtes-vous sûr de ne pas mélanger
délire profond et délit de fuite je vous
le demande Serge vous quitte poisson
aussi
délire de fuite ou des lits
[Musique]